frente a la isla de arousa al amanecer
un centenar de barcos prenden sus
motores
aquí la pesca tradicional de almejas es
un negocio familiar josé y su hermano
llevan más de 30 años trabajando juntos
y esta especie que es la de japónica
está del tamaño establecido por las
juntas son 35 milímetros nosotros en
nuestros bancos lo tenemos a 38 entonces
ya son 3 milímetros a mayores para
garantizar que pueda tener una capacidad
de reproducción más grandes
para estas embarcaciones la normativa
europea quiere hacer obligatorio un
sistema de geolocalización a bordo y que
lleven un diario de pesca electrónico en
tiempo real
qué es la tristeza es esa hay mucha
gente que regula el sector y lo
desconoce completamente
nosotros somos embarcaciones muy
pequeñitas embarcaciones muy pequeñitas
que trabajan muy cerca de puerto no
disponemos de zonas estanques donde
poder tener material electrónico ni nada
porque no es posible
sin embargo ya existe un sistema de
control que incluso fue reforzado hace
dos años por las autoridades españolas
este obliga a los pescadores a pasar
cada día por esta plataforma situada en
medio de la zona de pesca para mostrar
su pesca aquí lleva la sólida no lleva
nada
el objetivo es que no vaya marisco
ilegal que no tenga que no tenga talla
parada para el mercado y que no lleven
más del peso permitido dependiendo de la
especie las cuotas varían entre 500
gramos y 5 kilogramos
esto mira para todas
en cuanto llega al muelle la
trazabilidad continua gracias a una
última etapa de verificación
la embarcación tiene un número que se
pone aquí y le sale lo que pesa de cada
especie estas máquinas y estos
clasificados nosotros están
subvencionadas por fondos europeos o
este es un ordenador en sí que está
conectado al sistema de la xunta si lo
estamos haciendo yo lo veo absurdo y
dinero tirado al aire
en su lucha contra estas nuevas
directivas europeas los pescadores
pueden contar con el apoyo de la
consejera del mar del gobierno local de
galicia
somos la primera región pesquera de toda
la unión europea por lo tanto nuestras
zonas costeras tenemos 82 ayuntamientos
costeros que dependen fundamentalmente
de esta actividad y si les ponemos
medidas que ellos no las entiendan no
las comparten y no sean capaces de
valorar lo de positivo que estas medidas
les acercan lo único que estamos
haciendo es desincentivar a la juventud
para que siga habiendo en la pesca una
actividad de futuro
[Música]
los pescadores gallegos ya han
paralizado toda su flota en varias
ocasiones una forma de advertirle a
bruselas
es la primera vez que nos movilizamos
aunque tenemos estar con forma de no
estar conforme con unas normativas o con
otras más bien pero de esta tocar un
fondo está vimos que no estaban
implicando unas normas que va a ser
imposible que las podamos comprar
el responsable de la federación de
cofradías no se rendirá
somos casi cuatro mil embarcaciones que
dependemos de esto y nada vamos a ver
cómo van las negociaciones pero nos
vamos a seguir manifestándonos todo sino
que todos los meses de 22 meses lo único
que queremos es trabajar no queremos
y que se nos trate como delincuentes
sino como lo que son los trabajadores y
familias del mar
no obstante la eurodiputada que está
detrás del reglamento es una española
su prioridad es obtener una norma común
para los 27 estados miembros
queremos tener todos los datos de
captura una armonización y una
aplicación por igual en todos los países
y que no haya discriminación porque hay
países que sancionan más a los
pescadores que a otros y eso en europa
no debiera ser en los próximos meses el
texto será examinado por todas las
instituciones europeas
este es un momento decisivo para galicia
que reclama una excepción para la pesca
artesanal